there's such a currency to victimhood
especially to racial victimhood that
everyone's trying to claim it and when
they can't claim it because
there is there is no anti-black
oppression there's no systemic racism
there's no anti-woman misogyny patriarch
it's all you know that is a fantasy of
the libs because of that they have to
invent it this is what you're seeing
right now at byu brigham young
university you may have heard of this
story i didn't even report on it because
i knew it was bogus from the beginning
but the headlines
for weeks now have been
that
there was a racist incident during a
brigham young
volleyball game it was duke versus
brigham young
and the duke volleyball player rachel
richardson claimed that byu fans
yelled racial slurs at her during the
game
byu that's that's the mormon university
mormons probably the nicest and most
polite people who have ever walked the
face of the earth they're apparently
screaming yelling racial slurs so the
minute i saw that i said nope that
didn't happen
there's just no way i would bet
i would bet
probably my life savings that that
didn't happen
at all nothing even resembling that
happened
then the day after the game this duke
player's godmother lisa pamplin
who's a lib politician who is running
for number five judge of tarrant county
criminal court tweeted out quote my
goddaughter is the only black starter
for duke's volleyball team while playing
yesterday she was called a and the n
word you're not even allowed to say the
word that's
that's how systemically racist america
is against black people there's there's
only one word in the entire english
language you are not allowed to say
right now and it's the word that would
be offensive to black people and she was
called that word for every time she
served
then
in comes lebron james of course lebron
james one of the wealthiest most
privileged people in america who says
black men can't walk outside their door
without being hunted down by racist
police so lebron james of course not a
whole lot going on in between those
years he decides to chime in he believes
the thing hook line and sinker he says
lisa pamplin you tell your goddaughter
to stand tall be proud and continue to
be black we're a brotherhood and
sisterhood we have her back this is not
sports
and then richardson herself chimed in
said friday night in our match against
brigham young my fellow african-american
teammates and i were targeted and
racially racially heckled throughout the
entirety of the match the slurs and
comments grew into threats okay which
caused us to feel unsafe so hold on
initially it was we were called names
then it was we were called the n-word
then it was we were
directly threatened not just me by the
way my whole all the black players even
though apparently i thought she was the
only black player whatever
as a result of this
uh south carolina women's basketball
team decided to cancel its home and home
series with brigham young there was a
national outcry you know because of how
systemically racist america is
everyone's just starts to cancel byu
because because to even have this slight
insinuation that you might be in any way
racist against black people it will
destroy your entire life
and then byu does an investigation
and finds
zero evidence that anything like this
took place
it never happened
all of the cultural forces in america
are pressuring byu
to find any evidence of this
and and byu couldn't
because it obviously didn't happen of
course
of course because none of these things
are real they're always hoaxes it's you
your reaction
two headlines about this is the most
interesting thing about the stories i
don't mean you you're if you're
listening to the show you're very
sensible people but i mean americans
generally i had a friend this is right
after trump wins friend of mine in la
very very liberal
he says michael the racism the ku klux
klan has been unleashed in america i
said i don't think so actually you know
a lot of black people who voted for
trump i don't really i don't really buy
that he says no michael i don't michael
i was driving down in west hollywood and
i saw a sign and it it said black people
not wanted here i don't i forget the
exact wording but there's something to
the effect go away black people we don't
like you
can you imagine michael in west
hollywood the forces of racism have been
unleashed i said hey buddy buddy
repeat what you just said
in west hollywood
which is the most liberal
part of one of the most liberal cities
one of the most liberal states
you're seeing this sign so either there
is explicit either the ku klux klan is
all libs
or
it's a hoax it's not real
it was put up
by either a black person who is trying
to get some kind of
victim status
or in west hollywood more likely
probably just a liberal white person
who is trying to
pretend
that there is this awful culture of
racism you know
to engage in a lie but the lie tells a
greater truth that's what the libs
always say when they get caught in a lie
but i'm sure and that isolated incident
i don't know there was not even any
reporting about this sign that my buddy
saw i i promise you that was a hoax but
and the way i that i know that that was
a hoax is that they always are hoaxes
okay
these kinds of incidents have been going
on
especially on campuses
like byu but on campuses around the
country these things have been going on
for 50 years now or more and they have
been increasing in frequency
constantly
over the last five or six years really
beginning with the trump administration
because the libs had this narrative to
sell that trump is a big racist and the
conservatives are the ku klux klan and
so because there was no evidence of that
they had to
fabricate it the demand for anti-black
racism is very very high the supply is
very very small and so they have to
manufacture the supply that's exactly
what they did
byu turns out the race the racial hate
incident was a total hoax
1969
cornell university willard strait hall
you have black power activists who are
demanding the creation of an
african-american studies center
an african-american studies department
african-american studies is a fake
academic discipline but in the 60s these
kind of critical theory disciplines were
cropping up everywhere and so these
activists at cornell wanted one and they
weren't going to get one because it's a
fake academic discipline so then what do
you know a burning cross shows up in
front of one of the black groups on
campus
and as a result of this there's a
major
incident you have black power activists
with guns holding people hostage on
campus and as a result the university
caves and creates the afm studies
department now the most curious thing
about this whole incident
is they never found out who put up that
burning cross
they never found any of those ku klux
klansmen on campus
in fact
they found a lot of evidence
that the black power activists burned
the cross themselves of course why
wouldn't they
by by feigning victimhood they got
everything that they wanted
obviously jesse smalley that's the
greatest example you got this basically
unknown actor from a show that pretty
much nobody watched walking around
chicago downtown chicago a city that had
been governed by libs for almost 100
years at that point exclusively by lives
by one of the most notorious democrat
machines and then it just so happens
that there were two
klansmen maga hat wearing men out on the
street looking for this obscure actor
and carrying rope to to lynch him
wearing the maga hats and then jesse
smallette fought them off while holding
a subway sandwich it never made any
sense
half of the country believed it more
than half the country believed it's
millet
even in the most ridiculous version of
this
that's the power of the narrative
2016
three black students in at oberlin
college
accused a bakery and liquor store owner
of of racially profiling them
discriminating against them
major major incident oberlin cuts the
contract totally defames this poor
little bakery and it turns out no the
kids were lying they were trying to rob
the store they were trying to steal
booze they completely made it up and
everyone bought into it hook line and
sinker except for those of us who know
that all every single one of these
incidents is a hoax unfortunately now in
court the court
when presented with all this evidence
actually uh found in favor of the bakery
but but too little too late the baker
actually ended up dying and oberlin
still hasn't totally paid them out
what about 2016 that same year bowling
green state university there was
allegedly an incident of rock hurling
white trump supporters
throwing these these rocks at a black
student the only evidence of racism or
violence that investigators could find
was a trove of text messages from the
black student who had
concocted this story
the student had sent her her boyfriend
texts disparaging white people and
wishing death upon trump supporters and
saying that she wished we would all get
aids
okay
2017 st olaf college in minnesota a
black student left a racist threat on
her own car
there was an oh here's a threat the
klan's going through minnesota no she
wrote it herself 2017.
five black air force academy cadets
found racial slurs on their doors oh no
the clan is active at the air force
right no turns out investigation proved
they wrote the threats themselves and
the slurs themselves 2018 a black
student at goucher college
found
uh in in a dorm room bathroom i'm gonna
kill all n-words big uproar here we go
the clan is back and reasonable people
knew this was obviously fake and it
turns out yes the kid wrote the slur
himself and the irony of it is i guess
the kid is technically black if you look
at a picture of him he doesn't look
black at all you wouldn't know even know
that he was black
so even the idea that he would have been
targeted is completely preposterous
he doesn't not that he wouldn't have
been targeted anyway because this stuff
doesn't exist because it's all made up
because it's all
it has to be fabricated for the demand
right now go to podium.com knowles a lot
of people hate calling a business and
would much rather just send a quick
message if you're running a business and
the only way to get in touch with you is
a phone number you might be losing
people podium gives businesses the tools
to compete with the convenience offered
by bigger businesses or huge companies
like amazon from health care providers
to plumbers over 100 000 businesses are
texting with customers through podium
customers love the convenience
businesses love the results one car
dealer sold a 50 000 truck in just four
text messages with podiums all in one
inbox you can do even more than just
chat get more online reviews by sending
an easy to use link collect payments
fast from anywhere and send marketing
campaigns that actually get a response
all by sending a quick text see how
podium can grow your business watch a
demo today at podium.com knowles that's
podium.com slash knowles podium
let's
grow
i'm glad you like that clip now
hold on ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications that way we'll go from 1
million subscribers to 1 billion in no
time check it out we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you